[Music]
all this week we've taken you to cities
along the west coast to investigate
homelessness in this country from the
beginning we plan to show how much the
problem has grown but even we were
shocked by the scale of the epidemic in
the places we visited the homeless were
not just a problem in rich economic hubs
at San Francisco but also in dying
post-industrial cities in college towns
even in rural areas the investigation
was a little bit stronger than we
thought it was going to be and the
reaction has been much more profound
than we anticipated - in Sacramento
Police prom performed a warrant sweep at
the city's riverfront encampment the day
after our package aired 30 people were
arrested but most of the encampments
remain and they're threatening the
structural integrity of the city's levee
system in Seattle we reported the
shocking drug problems at a tenting
caman off of Interstate five Seattle
police raided that camp yesterday and
confiscated huge quantities of crack
cocaine heroin methamphetamine marijuana
firearms and machetes they even took a
sword they planned to evict the
residents and clear that camp next week
but small efforts like this are also
unequal to the problem which again is
growing the fact is that homelessness is
America's forgotten crisis Beltway
journalists spend their days in Twitter
competitions trying to prove they're the
best at hating Trump or opposing Russia
career bureaucrats obsessed over
toppling governments in Iran or
Venezuela they refuse to acknowledge the
problem steadily eroding the country we
actually live in America's homeless
population is huge and growing according
to the government even as the homeless
population Rises the number of people in
shelters is dropping that means more
people on the streets more garbage more
needles more human waste more human
misery of course we could build more
shelters and provide more treatment for
mental illness and addiction we could
clean up our parks and our sidewalks in
our riverbanks local governments have
shown themselves bizarrely unwilling to
do any of that those strategies would
help but they don't confront the
underlying problem why are so many
people winding up living outside in this
country to answer that question would
require investigating and
fixing far deeper ailments opioids must
be treated like what they are they're
the single greatest public health crisis
to face America since the Spanish flu a
century ago we need to find a real way
to lower housing prices and provide a
path for working-class people to own
homes instead of selling the country to
Chinese investors and prioritizing
returns of real estate speculators which
is what we now do we need to honestly
address the collapse of families we need
to implement policies that would keep
them together or these try we need to
stop viewing struggling Americans as
defective people who deserve to be
replaced by superior foreign immigrants
the Pelosi model but perhaps most of all
we need to look at the ways modernity is
destroying people modern technology
modern careers modern culture are making
people depressed let's be honest making
people addicted insecure in some cases
many cases making them insane for these
problems the homeless are just the most
visible reflection of much greater
societal emergency some of these
problems are easy to solve others are
not but homelessness is an American
crisis and it's getting worse
we promised to continue covering it as
long as it takes for things to get
better because a country as noble and
prosperous as ours should never have
people living in tents in public parks